the midas list ranks the world's top
venture capitalists based off their
portfolio of startup investments that
includes realized actual returns so
companies that have gone public or been
acquired by other companies or companies
that have raised at a much higher
valuation than when the investor first
backed the company covering venture
capital is cool because it's kind of
like a cheat sheet to what companies are
becoming big and important within
technology the companies that are
driving people onto the midas list
because they have you know a high value
for their portfolio are also becoming
you know big important companies whether
it's snapchat it's uber back in the day
or more recently coinbase or airbnb or
in china maichuan or bite dance
for a long time we had the same couple
people at the top of the midas list but
in the last couple years we've seen more
movement at the top this year we had a
new number one and number two that were
reflecting trends and changes within the
tech landscape as well so at number one
we had chris dixon he's a general
partner at andreessen horowitz and he
runs their crypto fund a16z crypto it
was really fun to write about chris and
go deep into his story because he's a
two-time entrepreneur who was originally
based in new york then he moved out west
and he became a vc looking to spot the
next big thing you know moonshots like
drones or 3d printing or artificial
intelligence in the end he settled on
crypto and he was an early investor in
coinbase ripple and a few others the
coinbase investment was one of his big
midas drivers but he's also in a bunch
of really interesting companies today
whether it's dapper labs the maker of
nfts for the nba nba top shot or dydx a
decentralized exchange and chris has
really become you know this elder
statesman in the crypto community as a
long-time venture capitalist and
entrepreneur who's also blogged and
showed a lot of credibility and thought
leadership in the space over a long
period
over the years we do see trends of
companies coming and going and having a
huge impact on the list early in my
career that was facebook which put
investors on the list for many years
then you had uber and and now more
recently we've seen airbnb doordash and
some of these consumer internet
companies really driving the list even
while it's still private bike dance in
china is another really big driver here
and then of course crypto
and fintech are so important these days
and we really have seen their investors
shine we had 12 investors from coinbase
on the midas list third of any company
after stripe and airbnb and then we also
had number two on the list mickey malka
a venezuelan-born investor who was both
in coinbase and in new bank so he's
straddling the world of crypto and
fintech which is how he did so well on
this year's list there are 11 women on
this year's midas list one fewer than
last year's record tying 12. we have
seen that number creep up over the years
that i've been doing midas but it is a
stark reminder of the need for
improvement across the venture capital
industry one cool thing that we saw this
year with the midas list was a record
representation from europe israel and
the middle east we had 12 investors from
those regions on the list this year
that's up 50 from eight last year and
it's a record for the midas list whether
it's aden in the netherlands or it's
revolut based in london or checkout.com
and then you have klarna and other
breakout companies in the nordics these
companies are suddenly valued in the
tens of billions another cool thing
about this year's midas list is that we
decided to expand it
one of the few expansions we've done in
21 years to include a new list called
the midas seed
the midas seed is a list of the top 25
seed stage only investors so these are
early stage specialists who tend to
write smaller checks
into companies when they are really
small sometimes even just an idea so
sometimes those investors haven't always
been recognized by the midas model
because the midas list looks at venture
capital across every stage and size we
thought that it would be exciting this
year to have a list of just 25 seed
investors
using the similar data that we're
getting from the midas list but changing
the criteria a little bit to better
reflect the check sizes they're writing
the ultimate result was a list of both
midas stalwarts and exciting newcomers
some under the radar vcs who have really
built a good track record others up and
comers like nick tomano at one
confirmation who's a crypto specialist
the nice thing about the midas list is
that we've been doing it for 21 years
and so we have a pretty impressive
database of information that we've
collected with our long time data
partner true bridge capital partners and
to this day we still have firms more
every year dozens of firms submit their
data confidentially we don't use the
data to report without re-reporting it
but it's very important to go down to
this partner level detail to really
understand what the real results are
here you know the midas list is not just
a popularity contest then we do of
course look at publicly available data
sets for people who don't want to submit
for the list so overall we have
visibility into hundreds if not
thousands of partners across dozens of
vc firms and this data goes back many
years and we like to think that this is
the most data-driven list of any in its
kind
[Music]
you